En apparence,
les héros les plus connus de notre pop-culture
n’ont pas les même origines.
Ils ne sont pas devenus des héros de la même
manière.
Si certains sont plus humains,
donc plus proches de nous,
d’autres ont acquis un pouvoir,
et certains sont même nés avec.
Mais ces différences sont en réalité superficielles,
parce qu’il n’existerait qu’une seule
et unique manière
de devenir un héros.
Je suis Romain,
et vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
À en croire ce livre,
Le héros aux mille et un visages de Joseph
Campbell,
toutes les cultures sans exception partagent,
à travers leurs différents mythes,
le même archétype du héros.
Joseph Campbell appelle ça « le monomythe
».
La raison profonde en est
que tous les récits seraient liés entre
eux dans l'imaginaire humain
en tant que manifestations d'un besoin universel
d'expliquer les réalités sociales,
cosmologiques, et spirituelles.
Ce que cette hypothèse explique,
c’est que l’aventure du héros serait
en fait une allégorie
de la manière dont tout homme
peut parvenir à la maturité spirituelle.
Je vais illustrer cette idée
tout au long de la vidéo
avec plusieurs héros hollywoodiens
- Batman, Spiderman, Superman, et Néo de
Matrix.
Comme Joseph Campbell aime beaucoup la psychanalyse,
il montre avec ses outils d’analyse
que les lieux, les personnages, et les objets
des mythes
y ont la même fonction que dans le rêve
:
ils travestissent l’évolution de l’âme
le long du destin individuel.
Le grand enseignement de cette démystification
de la mythologie,
c’est que le héros,
eh bien c’est chacun d’entre nous.
L’aventure du héros,
avec ses étapes obligatoires,
c’est aussi,
c’est surtout la nôtre.
Chacun peut devenir un héros.
Un rien peut tout déclencher.
Un geste maladroit peut être le signe d’une
destinée,
parce que la théorie freudienne des actes
manqués
révèle qu’il est l’expression d’un
désir inconscient très profond.
Dans Spiderman, par exemple,
la piqûre d’araignée apparaît bien sûr
comme de la pure malchance,
mais ça n’est bien évidemment pas un hasard
si ça tombe sur Peter Parker.
Le destin le choisit lui,
parce qu’il en a le potentiel moral
- parce qu’il est déjà un héros dans
son coeur.
Mais l’appel de l’aventure est généralement
plus explicite.
Le futur héros est en quête de lui-même,
il se cherche,
ce qui montre bien qu’il est au seuil d’une
transformation spirituelle.
Son centre de gravité est attiré vers une
zone inconnue,
symbolisée, dans les récits mythologiques,
comme un pays lointain, une forêt, un royaume
souterrain, une île secrète, etc.
Les circonstances de l’appel ne sont jamais
anodines.
Elles présentent des signes du destin et
des épreuves à venir.
Enfin, le héros est parfois grossièrement
prédestiné,
comme Hercule qui étrangle un serpent dans
son berceau,
ou Clark Kent enfant qui soulève une voiture.
Malgré le pouvoir d’attraction de ces signes
du destin,
son appel peut rester sans réponse.
Mais ce n’est généralement qu’une hésitation
durable,
jusqu’à la révélation providentielle.
Le héros n’est pas seul dans son périple.
Après avoir accepté l’appel,
il reçoit souvent une aide surnaturelle de
la part d’une figure protectrice,
qui le prépare à affronter l’adversité
des épreuves à venir.
Le héros se méfie du guide,
mais il le suit de manière irrationnelle,
parce qu’il incarne l’influence bienveillante
et protectrice du destin.
Cette figure est la plupart du temps féminine,
comme la Vierge dans les légendes chrétiennes.
Elle est
plus rarement un personnage masculin :
tel un nain, un habitant des bois, un sorcier,
etc.
Elle est le guide qui fait franchir le seuil
d’un monde nouveau
au héros en devenir.
Le franchissement de ce seuil est une annihilation
de soi,
une mort symbolique nécessaire à la renaissance
héroïque.
C’est la phase préférée des récits mythologiques
:
ils la fond durer, ils la décrivent en détail.
Les scénaristes de Hollywood le savent bien
:
c’est une étape fondamentale du parcours
du héros.
Et certains n’hésitent pas à lui donner
explicitement le sens initiatique
auquel elle renvoie.
Les épreuves du héros,
ça correspond bien évidemment à l’initiation
du profane
dans les sociétés secrètes,
de l’Antiquité à nos jours.
Le but c’est de transformer le candidat,
pour en faire un homme nouveau,
régénéré moralement.
Pour Joseph Campbell,
les récits mythologiques ne font que rendre
visibles
toutes les constructions symboliques de l’imagination
qui sont présentes dans la psyché de n’importe
quel adulte.
Ce rapprochement révèle la véritable nature
des épreuves du héros :
ce ne sont pas des épreuves de force, d’endurance,
ou même de courage,
ce sont fondamentalement des épreuves morales.
Le véritable voyage du héros est en lui-même,
dans les profondeurs de son esprit.
Il ne pourra renaître qu’en mettant à
mort son ego.
Entamées par une mort intérieure,
les épreuves initiatiques aboutissent à
la renaissance.
Le héros est un nouvel homme.
Le succès de son périple est souvent concrétisé
par la conquête de la femme tentatrice,
qui symbolise en fait la conquête du destin.
La figure féminine peut même être la jauge
de la progression du héros.
Plus fondamentalement,
la fin des épreuves, c’est-à-dire l’apothéose,
signifie l’accession à un niveau quasi-divin.
Elle est parfois interprétée comme la recherche
de l’immortalité physique,
ou, sur le plan psychologique,
comme l’expression du fantasme d’invincibilité
de l’enfance,
mais c’est faire fausse route, pour Joseph
Campbell.
Le véritable sens de l’apothéose héroïque,
c’est que le corps et la personnalité physique
afférente
cessent désormais d’entraver la vision,
comme lorsque Néo réalise sa connexion intime
à la matrice.
La libération intérieure du héros s’accompagne
d’un nouveau rapport au cosmos :
il ne vit plus sur le seul plan physique,
mais dans tous les corps,
et à toutes les échelles du monde.
Le héros a découvert qu’il était lui-même
l’objet de sa propre quête,
il a embrassé son destin.
Il est prêt pour rentrer.
Mais rentrer n’est pas si simple que ça.
Parce que des puissances surnaturelles s’opposent
au retour.
Ces puissances, elles peuvent être un gardien,
des dieux, ou des démons,
qui désapprouvent le désir du héros de
réintégrer le monde profane.
Le retour est alors en lui-même comme une
épreuve de plus.
Autre cas de figure :
ce peut être la société qui,
jalouse de l’éloignement du héros,
se charge de le ramener au bercail.
Mais les problèmes ne s’arrêtent pas là.
Le héros qui réussit à rentrer est confronté
à l'imperméabilité des hommes :
Comment traduire son expérience pour diffuser
son message ?
Comment enseigner ce qui a été déjà correctement
enseigné
et incorrectement assimilé des milliers de
fois ?
On retrouve ce thème dans films modernes
quand l’opinion publique ne reconnaît plus
la valeur du héros,
ou même qu’elle en fait son bouc émissaire.
Que le héros et les hommes ne soient pas
sur la même longueur d'ondes
explique la fonction mythologique du vêtement
(celui du prêtre, ou de l’artiste, par
exemple),
qui sert à séparer l’individu spécial
du monde commun.
Vivre dans les deux mondes n’est pas chose
aisée ;
c’est un art de maître que de passer de
l’un à l’autre
sans confondre leurs principes.
Cette maîtrise est généralement l’apanage
de personnages particuliers,
comme des sages, des dieux travestis, etc.
Et c’est là que se séparent les destins
héroïques et les destins divins.
Le héros échoue généralement à devenir
le maître des deux mondes ;
c’est pourquoi il est nécessaire qu’un
nouveau héros émerge,
puis refasse,
à son tour,
le même parcours.
Un nouveau héros est nécessaire lorsque
des monstres primitifs ou des tyrans
menacent la communauté des hommes.
Ainsi, le héros est l’agent du cycle de
la vie :
il reproduit dans le monde l’élan initial
qui le mit en mouvement.
Alors, je trouve l’idée de Joseph Campbell
très intéressante,
et elle est probablement juste.
Il n’est pas étonnant qu’on la retrouve
dans les blockbusters hollywoodiens,
parce que le livre a beaucoup influencé les
scénaristes.
Et puis,
le sorcier qui racontait un mythe,
c’est un peu l’ancêtre du scénariste
!
Voici peut-être pourquoi les films de héros
plaisent tant.
C’est qu’exceptionnel en apparence,
le héros serait en réalité universel.
Il est tout homme sur le chemin spirituel
qui le mène à l’acceptation de son destin,
à épouser le mouvement de la vie,
et donc à en assumer pleinement l’inévitable
culpabilité.
En termes plus simples,
devenir un héros, ce serait atteindre une
forme de maturité stoïcienne,
en renonçant à ses fantasmes,
et en se fondant dans l’ordre du monde.
Et chacun peut se libérer intérieurement
ainsi
en suivant la voie du héros.
Si le travail de Joseph Campbell est très
descriptif,
il comporte aussi un message philosophique.
Selon lui, les forces du monde moderne
- la liberté démocratique, la méthode scientifique,
et la technique -
ont vidé les symboles mythologiques de leurs
pouvoirs.
Alors que ces symboles sont censés aider
l'individu à franchir ses horizons spirituels,
il n’y est plus sensible du tout.
L’homme moderne reste donc immature :
son âme est coupée en deux,
entre la zone consciente, et la zone inconsciente,
qui ne communiquent plus.
Pour Joseph Campbell,
le héros est plus que jamais nécessaire.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo,
mettez un pouce bleu
et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire mon article de blog inspiré de
la lecture de ce livre,
Le héros aux mille visages de Joseph Campbell
sur le site 1000 idées de culture générale,
voire pour pour lire le livre directement,
les liens sont dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale
synthétisées dans le format le plus clair
possible,
vous pouvez vous inscrire à la newsletter
en laissant votre adresse e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain
et sous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous vous n’avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête
pour vous intéresser au meilleur de la pensée.